might be a market for only two or three computers ever and wow was he wrong we
are all those early pioneers of computing but in this new field of quantum Computing and Quantum is often
contrasted with classical Computing as something distinctly different from it and often in competition with it but my
aim for this introductory lecture was to hopefully convince you that from an eagle eye view we can see Quantum
Computing as simply the next chapter and a long story of computing it is our nature as humans to seek out new ways to
compute and to harness the power of the natural world and to figure out what to do with it and we've been doing this for
centuries Quantum Computing offers us a new tool in this endeavor and it is up to us to discover how we can leverage
the power it offers us in the next lesson in the series we will talk a little bit more about 100 Cubit systems
and give an overview of kcit our qu software SDK and how to best interact with these machines right now thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time